you Integra Miriam oh sure yeah I'm not
asking any questions while the cheese is
in your mom won't feel compelled to keep
talking while the cheese is in your
mouth I'm John I'm a private
investigator I've been doing this for
about three years and today's the most
intriguing case of my career I am to
deduce which of these subjects has
damaged the dairy cheese product Oh will
you come here please
[Music]
what shame Spencer
where you from Boston where'd you go
high school was a co-ed no whoa we're to
go to college again for them all right
what's your favorite TV show the office
leave her character Dwight what's your
favorite food burgers cheese burgers
what's your favorite cheese good
[Music]
Bree this is like a murder and this is
so slimy and weird I don't want to touch
it cheeseburgers what do you put on your
cheeseburgers a combination of ketchup
and mayonnaise okay mustard I like
mustard not on my hamburger zone
cheeseburgers where's your favorite spot
to get a burger Shake Shack in a pen
Shake Shack did you cut the cheese all
right I think I'm good for now Spencer
thanks why don't you come and join me
please what's your name
Jana Jana what's your favorite movie
I'll go with 500 days of summer what's
your favorite comedy game night with
Rachel McAdams it's not the right one
yeah but yeah is that the most recent
one or your favorite I would say that's
my most recent favorite okay what's your
favorite food I really love chili cheese
spicy yeah where'd you get a good chili
cheese fry around here I really like the
one from Carl Street here but I guess
I'm partial cuz I used to work there and
you still eat there on occasion it's
good to know that's the best chili
cheese fries in Los Angeles is Carl's
jr. I mean I I have a fondness for it at
Carl's jr.
[Music]
it's a soft cheese in a in a warm room
what's your favorite cheese I really
like bringing ones last time he had
breed
I actually had it this past weekend I
had a picnic with a charcuterie board
Trader Joe's and when was that last
weekend not earlier today
where'd you go to high school I went to
Pacific high school where's that in San
Bernardino you live in LA now yes how
long seven years I I moved to LA for
college and then never has been ever
since okay so you're telling me you
didn't cut the cheese okay thank you for
your time
yeah I think I'm done for now I'm gonna
need you later though Thanks
oh man Lake hello Missy look you and I
both know this is just a formality I
know you wouldn't do me dirty so you're
like would you have for lunch all right
tacos from the taqueria right around the
corner from BuzzFeed so you didn't eat
on on campus no they don't have catering
on Tuesdays so you had tacos huh me
tacos for what Caillou you're a meat
eater oh yeah yeah they were desaad us
with onions and green sauce not
guacamole
was there cheese on the taco there was
no cheese now are you cheese guy
sometimes it is a healthier choice than
like Doritos so sometimes I'll grab like
baby bells you got any cheese at home
you know I have baby bells okay um and
then like sliced cheese for sandwiches
sandwich guy
so what's your sandwich situation I go
turkey with the turkey cheese lettuce
what type of cheese
probably like pepper jack or something
okay add a little something to it like
the white cheeses yeah sharp cheddar is
good though but it's more of an
emotional cheese though you think so
yeah you get a much more sharp cheddar
that makes me think are you fidgeting
are you nervous she cut the cheese no I
wish I would have though it looks like
delicious cheese would you like some
[Music]
I didn't taste though it thought it was
gonna taste them
he thought it'd taste better cuz he had
some already you know I mean it's my
first time but feels like it might have
been sitting there for a minute so
honest question is it any good I mean I
think it was at one point are you much
of a Brie guy yeah I mean I don't really
know all the names cheese's but like
whenever I get this Security plate or
whatever I like the pummels that they
bring to me so I think I'm dumb for now
Blake thank you would you join me yes
what's your name
Julie read from okay do you work here on
campus
yes are you an editor what's your
favorite food pineapple nice okay so
desert island one type of food yeah I
have made the mistake of eating too much
in one sitting apparently that can like
start to like cut up your mouth what's
your favorite meal I really like fried
chicken there's a good place what are
you that I'm gonna not say whichever
cheese probably the honey goat cheese
actually do Trader Joe's I know it well
do you like breathe yeah one's life time
you had brain probably I had a family
gathering sometimes we like to you know
serve some service of cheeses work she's
loving family okay so you and your
family get together they you have these
sort of shadowy vague cheese events and
then they're obviously a focal point of
your entire family structure but she and
yet you don't even recall the last time
you had brie cheese with I just want you
to look at that you're right
it's been mangled by an unsteady hand
shoemaker or a bricklayer perhaps not a
surgeon
this cheese tells a thousand tales but I
don't think Julie is a character okay
Julie thank you I think I'm done for the
time being so you could step to the wall
if you wish Jana would you come here
please you state you did not cut the
cheese Christ I did not cut the cheese I
just have you sign a dress this one was
tough but when there's forensic evidence
left behind it's beneficial Julie likes
pineapple claims to come from a very
cheesy family jana signed an affidavit
really states she didn't do it
Spencer's burned me in the past and I
heard undeniably the click-clack of her
whatever those are but I think it was an
active distraction background noise to
conceal the real fleet-footed
soft steppin perpetrator so swift to
rule yourself out you cut the cheese a
second time before I even asked you to
which was one of my plans all along I do
not believe the playback the playback
will indicate that I didn't tell you to
do it
all right I could be wrong however I
believe Blake cut the cheese
it's forensics man it's forensics you
laughed at me about inspecting the bite
mark I took a picture of it because this
is actually melting in front of me and
there's teeth marks on this thing
I knew it was a right hand at least
somebody who used their right hand to
cut because you can tell from the cheese
residue here that it was a right handed
cut unless somebody cut with their left
hand like that which is crazy I was
gonna try and get you to cut the cheese
or test your handwriting to see which
hand you wrote with which is also why I
did that to Janna
but yeah you were all about cutting that
cheese during the interrogation would
you like to cut the cheese
I knew you were clickity-clack in your
feet to make me think it was you people
online are gonna say oh he must have had
his eyes open somehow no I earned this I
wish I could eat it but it's evidence
[Music]